life is getting back to normal in many
places around the world as the danger
from the pandemic diminishes it's a
different story however in Hong Kong
large numbers of people have left the
city not only due to political unrest
but due to strict coveted policies
The Exodus includes many who work in
business and banking who form the
lifeblood of the city Elizabeth Palmer
has the story from Hong Kong
Hong Kong is one of the world's most
important Financial hubs it's the main
pipeline for money moving in and out of
Asia especially China but there's
trouble Brewing over the past year more
than a hundred thousand people have left
that's a record and multinational
companies are looking elsewhere too and
that makes Sally Wong is CEO of the Hong
Kong investment funds Association more
than a third of her members say they
have already moved jobs out to other
countries can you get them back where
have they gone from Singapore Dubai
Australia Japan you can name it the
pandemic hit Hong Kong hard for a while
this spring it had the highest coveted
mortality rate on Earth things are much
better now but as the rest of the world
moves on from the pandemic Hong kongers
still have to be fully masked and use an
app-based control system that's similar
to Mainland China's they have to scan
into public places with a QR code
including restaurants and newer Rivals
can't enter restaurants at all for three
days
High Flyers in banking who can work in
other Global Financial Centers are
voting with their feet disability or the
inability to travel freely in and out
definitely affects Hong Kong we need to
move back to normalcy 100 percent this
week Hong Kong's chief executive John
Lee made a pitch that he hopes will
reverse the talent outflow by offering
open work visas to college grads from
abroad but it may not be enough
in spite of the damage to Hong Kong's
economy and its reputation political
analysts thinks nothing is going to
change here until leaders in mainland
China who call the shots in Hong Kong
get rid of their zero covered policy and
right now there is no sign of that
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Elizabeth
Palmer in Hong Kong